bonjour bonjour poursuit cette même
source
san francisco font face à valenciennes
le vin
d'amasser 14 pas parce que la france est
maintenant pour le sketch il vaut mieux
parce que sinon ce sera dur est bon
alors je vous ai réunis aujourd'hui pour
la réunion oui la réunion commence parce
que quelqu'un du tabac marque soit pas
très gênant la bien je vous voyais donc
pour la réunion de la mjc une réunion
annuelle que l'on organise tous les ans
ou tous deux mois de travail c'est pour
faire un bilan de la mjc de notre
commune alors je vais faire un tour de
table
l'atelier poterie francis caillaux
évident de cette année et bien francis e
tu vois je crois que nous avons toujours
été franc les envers les autres alors je
vais faire le bilan
franchement tu vois et je suis devant un
échec
je suis donnera un échec je lave ou mon
projet de confectionner en poterie des
faucilles et des marteaux pour les
vendre à la fête de l'huma n'a pas
abouti je me suis trouvé devant deux
problèmes un problème pratique d'abord
c'est à dire qu'il y avait le nombre
d'etf aussi ne correspondait pas au
nombre des marteaux et deuxièmement j'ai
eu un problème de motivation de la part
des adhérents et ils ont tout cassé
j'ai gardé un mois et
ça n'a pas vraiment marché comme
j'aurais voulu que cette fois 6
est-ce que tu ne crois pas que pour
qu'on appelait yépes autres il tua un
petit peu payé les pots cassés pour ta
gestion d'un dernier c'est possible mais
donc tu étais éléments ont été décalés
issu des qualifs ici une insertion
sociale assez difficile du voile dans le
milieu culturel de la maison de jeunes
de la commune tous d'accord bien je
prends note de tout ce que tu viens de
dire merci à toi francine pour l'atelier
de danse musique
oui bah moi contrairement à francis ça
s'est plutôt bien passé parce que mon
effectif n'a pas changé je n'avais pas
des bons à quel point la prochaine
à la rigueur on peut s'attendre
peut-être pas une petite progression on
s'est bien passé est occupé d'autres
choses que l'atelier d'opéra il n'y a
pas eu vraiment progression un peu mais
c'est qu'on va dépenser peut-être à
élargir l'atelier en mettant peut-être
un atelier cuisine
we dance music cuisine mais aussi
parallèlement à la cuisine m ancien
atelier régis parce que j'ai peur que le
cours de danse alors là ça marche est
d'accord on va atelier danse musique
cuisine régime ça me paraît bien droits
de la femme aussi étonné que tu n'as pas
d'élèves qui comptent occuper de ça
c'est toute façon j'ai téléphoné au
maire il m'a dit tu aurais pas de
problème cette année on en avait plus de
fric non plus de subvention de chez sony
bien en ce qui te concerne l'atelier
judo littérature et bien l'atelier judo
littérature ça s'est très très bien
passé on a travaillé un petit peu sur de
nouveaux ateliers parce que j'aime bien
diversifié un petit peu sur l'atelier
recherche et découverte de l'inconnu
on a travaillé un petit peu je ne vous
cacherai rien en vous disant toute la
partie recherche s'est très bien passé
pour ce qui est laïque ouverte
on est en train d'évoluer mais j'espère
pourquoi pas arriver à des résultats
prochainement le dire de la place encore
dans ton atelier l'écoutent je crois que
ces chats nous restons ouverts le plus
possible nous pas pour accueillir
c'est l'esprit delà de la libye c'est
parce que les charges je vous rappelle
qu'au mjc doit être une maison de fait
une maison des jeunes et de la culture
s'échapperait la rue qui me concerne
moi je vais monter quatre pièces de
brecht l'année dernière je vais changer
radicalement pour cette année puisque je
vais monter cinq pièces de brecht
lorsque c'est un bon choix tu vois pas
ce que j'aime tes mises en scène de
brecht qui excellent dans ce style est
tellement ça me fait plaisir pour
l'année qui va venir trouver comment le
spectacle que tu n'as pas vu écoute j'ai
éprouvé jeu et trouver j'ai eu de très
bons échos sur le quatrième et alors ça
coupe le troisième oui oui parce que le
troisième je n'avais pas vu non plus
mais il m'avait dit certaines choses en
général du temps avec a pas beaucoup de
monde dans les salles d hugo sont ces
bons bien maintenant nous avons parlé
aussi vous le voulez bien des projets à
l'avenir alors laquelle ils produiront
donc alors face à mon échec je vais
remercier la vapeur j'ai trouvé une
nouvelle solution je vais ouvrir un
atelier de pâte à modeler sur le plan
pratique ça coûte moins cher la pâte à
modeler et est bonne à modeler et en ce
qui concerne les problèmes caractériel
des adhérents ça fait moins mal
alors j'ai un autre projet je voudrais
animé un atelier d'animation au former
des animateurs pour animer d'autres
ateliers
c'est très très important
on a une équipe qui se réduit un petit
peu donc si francis propose de trouver
des gens qui nous aident
en ce qui concerne les veillées ou les
bas dont on n'est pas dans les veillées
j'ai remarqué y avait beaucoup de gens
qui n'avaient rien à dire je pense qu'il
faudrait qu'ils se réunissent et qu'ils
en bas
c'est bien pour le changer de la
prochaine veillée au sujet des veillées
je m'en vais vous faire une proposition
si c'est possible j'aimerais que les
veillées se passe le matin
simone et soir on aurait peut-être plus
de morale position télévisée match de
foot et au japon bien j'ai lu que tu
n'avais pas demandé de subvention cette
année et pourquoi pas oui on en a parlé
si tu ne sais tu n'utilises pas argent
qui t'ont donné cette année tu n'auras
rien les projets le haut niveau et ont
baissé le budget non bon ben je crois
que le mieux c'est que anneaux mohamed
oui ce soir quand tu brûleras les
feuilles mortes oui tu passes par
l'atelier danse il ya des futures études
et brûlent d'accord tu vois le tout
comme ça on demandera de support serait
que j'étais comme ça parce que tu
comprend l'état lui donne un il te
prends voici le contraire mais en fait
tu m'as compris bien que toi quels sont
tes projets français mais moi mes
projets j'aimerais dans mon atelier vu
d'eau parce que c'est quand même mon
atelier principales maisons
j'aimerais s'il avait été possible qu'on
puisse acheter cette année des ceintures
des simplement parce que parce que
l'année dernière nous avions acheté les
kimonos et on a beau dire
les kimonos ont tendance à tomber donc
c'est vrai active cette année si on
pouvait acheter les ceintures ce serait
bien on pas se leurrer si tu as beaucoup
d'élèves
oui
l'atelier devenu mixte bon d'accord mais
s'il était possible également j'aimerais
des ceintures de couleurs ça fait
plaisir aux participants et ça leur
permettrait de se reconnaître dans le
cours commence très bien bien alors
maintenant je vais aborder un problème
les problèmes de la mjc alors il ya des
problèmes graves
la machine à jus de fruits et casser ces
saucisses la machine alors ça fait un
mois hier ya des frais convenez que nous
avons changé de gouvernement à la mairie
il va falloir acheter une lettre parce
qu'avant c'était le pc maintenant c'est
le ps pour les banderoles il va falloir
changer les noms et les flyers ont fait
les efforts sur le budget si en plus on
achète et lettres non c'est d'ailleurs
moi tu veux pas y couper on ne peut pas
y couper
bon mais ensuite il ya un problème grave
c'est la faute aux l'atelier photo ils
n'ont plus de chambre noire ce qui fait
qu'on produit
photo du bal de la semaine dernière sont
foutus il n'ya pas les photos du mal non
seulement non mais c'est pas vrai il a
lavé kanak a fait casser
oui bah oui mon bateau flashback n'y a
rien de problèmes l'atelier spéléo
réclament des cordes mais ça fait quinze
jours qu'ils réclament les cordes bon
dieu tu sais pas tu te tapes a commandé
les cordes ya pas de cordes encore à
tanger tétouan et j'aurai un jeu indé
parler alors jacques oui est-ce que tu
s'est occupée des corps pour l'atelier
vidéo n'ont pas fait le ménage se fait
mais c'est pas possible mais non mais
les gosses belle ikos attendre une
semaine pour aller courir les boss et
son ventre ça fait dix ans qu'ils sont
dans tous aux attentes des corses mais
ce n'est pas grave on commence à ses
parts avant le super women encore je te
comprends par contre pour la machine à
café a lâché de capitaux reçus portois
de régresser